welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jennifer Prager an associate
professor of public health at Yale
University she has authored numerous
theoretical and empirical studies on the
equity and efficiency of health system
access financing resource allocation
policy reform and social determinants of
health these contributions are unified
by an overarching interest in equity and
disparities in health and health care
focusing on vulnerable and impoverished
populations nationally and globally
today we talk with Professor Ruger about
her new book health and social justice
welcome professor Kreuger thank you for
having me what led you to write your
book I was interested in addressing
several social problems that exists that
relate to health and how societies
across the world organize or fail to
organize to address health issues some
of these problems relate to differences
or disparities and health outcomes so
differences in under-five mortality
differences in adult mortality or
premature mortality changes within the
ability to be healthy over time and the
course of life also different social
problems related to health with respect
to access to health care differences in
access to quality of health care our
medically appropriate and medically
necessary health care the fact that
there are differences in people's
financial protection for their health
out-of-pocket payments can be exorbitant
for many people and the lack of
insurance to cover the cost of health
care can be very problematic for
individuals and also for societies
because we shift those costs when
they're not paid to others they can
cause individuals to be bankrupt they
can cause state governments to be
strapped with expenditures
there's also a great differences in how
societies allocate resources to health
the United States for example that
spends more than any other country on
health care on a per capita basis is
ranked 74th in the world in terms of
health outcomes and then and then also
questions about the norms and values
that the citizens of any society have
about health issues and how that relates
to the policy decisions that are made at
the state and the sub-national level so
these types of social problems are
issues with respect to health where of
interest to me in in writing the book
they collectively organized around a
concept that's discussed in the book
called health capability which is the
ability to be healthy okay so
differences for example in health
outcomes occur in any society and and
and can't guarantee equal health people
are different differentially predisposed
to health based on genetic or biological
factors so equal health outcomes isn't
isn't a possibility in terms of a social
guarantee however the equal opportunity
to be healthy sure the ability to be
healthy is something that is a problem
that we we should act about accessing
and the access issues yes one of the
things you do in your book is you look
at a variety of different current
medical and health frameworks that are
in place now and then you kind of cite
the problems around those frameworks
let's talk a little bit about that okay
there are a number of different ways or
philosophies in which different
societies tackle these issues one
approach on one end of the spectrum is
to just let individuals be responsible
for their health and their health care
and and basically allocate health care
and the resources for health whether
they be public health or health care
prevention or treatment through the free
market and so people's ability to pay
whether they have money or not on their
willingness to pay for for health care
is is really the way to go and that's
that's really the the framework in in
many developing countries and how
it's been the framework in the United
States although we do have a mixed
system on the other end of the spectrum
is is a more of a command and control
that you know that the government is
entirely responsible for the health of
its population and and a focus on on
outcomes like maximizing the health of
the population on the average health now
there are there issues with with both
ends of those spectrum and in between as
well okay and what country could you
cite as having that kind so on the more
commanding control is just typically the
former Soviet countries and in this type
of of approach so there and then there's
systems that are in between the the
problems with those different frameworks
are not on the on the free market side
or libertarian side of course there are
mark what we call market failures there
are lots of problems with healthcare
that are different than other types of
goods like chairs and tables and and
rugs there are externalities with
respect to healthcare so we have
infectious agents or you know we want to
make sure that people don't spread
disease throughout the population and so
we have an interest in in a social
interest in people consuming healthcare
that mean they may not be able to buy
through the market for example there are
externalities in the cost of health care
even if people don't have health
insurance and can't pay for it they
still need it and so they get it and so
somebody pays for the cost even if that
person can't pay there are a symmetries
of information or differences in the
ability to understand knowledge so
that's why we have doctors and nurses
and providers who have a wealth of
knowledge and information about
healthcare and are specialists in
individuals who are lay people and have
a certain amount of knowledge but
certainly aren't as expert as a
physician so it's different from buying
a pair of shoes as compared to trying to
decide about a surgery or a treatment so
these types of failures in the market
and the also the fact that healthcare is
a met what we call merit good which is
we need health care and we need
preventive services rather than just
desire them or want them so these are
the problems with that type of approach
which justifies or provides a motivation
for much more of a government or
societal role on the on the other side
the command and control are the more
focused on the collective it doesn't
take adequate consideration of
individuals and individuals needs and
the fact that there are the ability to
be healthy is is really something that
all individuals need to be conscious of
and we need to be thinking about
individual needs as well as the societal
needs so something some work somewhat in
the middle okay and and and a hybrid of
these approaches is really where we want
to be okay and you've you've developed
an alternative to those frameworks let's
talk about your it's the health
capability paradigm so tell us about
that so the health capability paradigm
is that is sort of a shift in thinking
about this health capability is an idea
that again goes back to our saying
earlier it's it's more about the ability
to be healthy or the opportunity to be
healthy which involves creating the
conditions external conditions and
internal conditions for individuals to
be healthy so on the external side okay
you know society or you know our
collective what we do in our public
policies whether we create regulations
we create financing systems we create
delivery systems we create public goods
of medical knowledge and information we
regulate doctors and how they deliver
care and whether they're meeting certain
standards these types of external
factors whether people have enough food
and food policies and and things like
that have a lot to do with whether or
not you I have an ability to be healthy
we have the chance to be healthy and a
regulation of our environment and things
like that
but there's also internal
characteristics so people make
individual choices we make choices about
our diet about our lifestyle about what
we you know what we do do we exercise do
we not you know do we do we take
preventive measures do we smoke do we
smoke or not you know
sorts of individual habits and and so in
in a concept called an individual health
agency which is our ability to achieve
health goals that we value do we have
the skills to do that do can we make
cost-benefit trade-offs or look at risks
of our you know and and and the benefits
do we have the information and knowledge
to do that so this is at the center of
this this this paradigm and then there's
it's a comprehensive approach that looks
at specific policy areas to address the
ability to be healthy like like access
to health care and access to preventive
measures whether or not the the the on
the external side there's a regulation
of the quality in the appropriateness of
medical care care casts to be
appropriate so in your paradigm in your
paradigm every would at would everyone
have access to health care yes but it's
not just just any old health care I mean
poor quality health care can actually
mean poor outcomes sure and differences
and outcomes and this may be you know
part of what is is driving these and
actually over utilization of health care
could be less healthy and more costly
sure and so some sort of recognition of
that and regulation oversight of that is
very important also on the financing of
health care we know from social
scientific research that pooling risk
across a large population reduces the
cost of health care for everybody and is
more as more equitable and efficient in
terms of financing health care it also
reduces these negative impacts of
out-of-pocket payments or when you pay
at the service because people may not
demand appropriate health care and it
may also cause them financial trouble
down the line so so financial protection
at the national level and equitable
financing would be part of this paradigm
also allocating resources more
efficiently and equitably they mentioned
that the u.s. spends more than many of
the country is ranked 74th and health
outcomes
that shows that there's a problem that
we're not allocating resources
efficiently and we also have you know
millions of 30 million people who aren't
even in the system I haven't been in the
system so there's something there's a
disconnect there and and and improving
those allocations are important and then
the focus on the norms and the common
knowledge in a population about this
goal and this objective because it takes
individuals and it takes society it
takes groups of doctors it takes it
takes the government in all levels to be
involved in this so I think better
education a better communication about
values and norms with respect to health
and and both individual health and
population health are really part of
this as well I I believe that the
financial aspect is probably the largest
obstacle I think too many people
believing that the 30 million people for
instance that do not have health
insurance how is giving them health
insurance going to impact what I am
paying for my health insurance yes how
does your paradigm adjust that yes well
we're paying for health insurance very
inefficiently and and in many other
countries as well it's not just the
American system as I said the
out-of-pocket expenditures in many
developing countries for example are are
very problematic so ensuring health
insurance through a larger risk pool we
know that the more people are in the
pool the more you can shift risks or
shift the cost from people who are are
healthy to people who aren't as healthy
from people who have have more money
people who don't have as much money
throughout the population in terms of
age younger people do tend to have less
utilization and and cost but older
people have more so if you if you have a
long term view and a comprehensive view
about it you can actually spread these
risks in these costs more efficiently
and it can cost less for everyone on a
per-capita basis
there's also important efforts to look
at the cost themselves and recognize
that the costs are too high for many
different types of procedures and
different parts of the medical care
complex we are more costly than other
competitor countries for example and so
diagnosing the underlying causes of
those costs in doing very specific and
rigorous cost analyses to really get at
the cost and separate what things really
cost from what we pay for them in terms
of the profit margin for example is very
important as well so there's a number of
different measures that can be taken
the profit margin I imagine is probably
very high in this country for the
medical profession it can be in some
areas and in some areas it's actually
low there are certain health systems
that are doing better with with less and
so we have positive examples of ways in
which better quality healthcare and you
know medically appropriate health care
can be provided at a lower cost and so
it's it there are some possibilities out
there and there are some actually
examples of proven ways in which this
can be done and so it's scaling it
uh-huh okay and your book has been out
there for about a year now I am curious
to know how it has had an effect on
public health and the medical frameworks
we know so are can you cite some of the
positive effects that that your paradigm
has had well sure so in in the area of
health insurance for example it's been
involved there's been involvement with
the with the current health reform
efforts focused on expanding health
insurance and in fact your book has been
noted in a Supreme Court Justice ruling
so talk a little bit about that - that's
kind of it that must be very exciting
for you well it's been very interesting
the the the issue of
health care being very different from
other types of services and goods as I
was mentioning buying health care
purchasing health care and purchasing
health insurance is very different and
people tend to equate it with other
types of services when that is is is not
really the case and so health insurance
there are reasons for health insurance
that are important that cover these you
know costs that we incur and the cost
that incur based on anybody could wake
up any day and have an unpredictable
health and that we can't predict when
we're going to be sick or when we're
going to be injured or it's very hard to
certainly we've tried to and so health
insurance provides that protection and
actually there's a social benefit to
health insurance as well as an
individual one and so the the question
has been whether or not we should have
people purchase health insurance to
protect themselves but the but the
question actually really should be are
we having and we asking people to
purchase health insurance to protect
themselves and protect society in terms
of the the transfer of cost and the
transfer of the different externalities
from not having health care or having
health care that and needing health care
that's not paid for what we call
uncompensated care are shifting of the
cost of care and this is something that
we know social scientifically occurs and
so the the shifting of cost creates
these inefficiencies in the system for
which advance purchase of health care or
advanced protection can perhaps not
fully eliminate but certainly protect
and in some measure at the individual
and the societal level okay and moving
forward what what would you like to see
happen particularly in the United States
and in terms of healthcare well I think
things are moving in the right direction
there are a number of different changes
that are occurring in both the policy
arena and the legislative arena
the new health reform law but also in
the private sector so in the book I
discuss a concept called shared health
governance which is really about the
idea that creating the ability to be
healthy for all individuals and and and
and the population as a whole is a team
effort
that we all have a role to play the
government has a role to play in these
protections and regulations and
oversight and investing in public goods
like medical knowledge and and
regulating services so they're high
quality and and register being resources
doctors and providers have a role in
terms of providing high quality services
individuals have a role to play in and
their own health and that responsibility
is collective that we have individual
responsibilities and society has a
responsibility and so it's not a
Republican or democratic thing it's not
a liberal or conservative thing it's a
human issue and about the human
condition that we're all part of the
producing of our own health
even so no individual benefits from the
the whole infrastructure alone it's it's
a collective and an interdependent and
codependent exercise and so to the
extent that we were moving more in that
direction which i think is in we have a
we have an opportunity in America to do
that because we have a strong
individualistic ethos but we also have
some examples of where we've come
forward for the collective our Medicare
program as a very good example and and
this gets to the issue of norms and
values some people say if you don't do
anything please don't let the government
take over Medicare but Medicare is a
government program so the disconnect
that I was talking about in terms of
what people understand and the values
and they what they know about our
programs versus what has happening in
policy I think needs to be bridged as
well as recognizing this notion of
shared effort and a shared
responsibility very good thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you for
more information about Professor Ruger
please visit our website at yale.edu
backslash McMillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
McMillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
McMillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale